el poder adquisitivo fue el tema
principal de la campaña presidencial
aunque en el último semestre de 2021
hubo una disminución general del
desempleo sigue siendo uno de los
desafíos más importantes ya que cerca
del 16 por ciento de los jóvenes seguía
sin empleo a finales de 2021 los
franceses también piden mejores salarios
y empleos menos precarios
vivir con 1.300 euros parecía imposible
tenemos un salario neto mínimo de 1800
euros porque nos parece el mínimo
realmente necesario para poder pagar
nuestros gastos el medio ambiente es
otra de las grandes preocupaciones se
demostró otra vez en una protesta en
parís este sábado
seguimos diciendo que este mandato de
cinco años es la última oportunidad de
materia ecológica y climática el ipc se
ha publicado un informe que nos dice una
vez más lo mucho que se está acelerando
esta crisis y que tenemos que tomar
medidas más rápidas para combatir el
cambio climático en 2021 el estado
francés fue condenado por el tribunal
administrativo de parís por su falta de
acción sobre la crisis climática
finalmente la guerra en ucrania se
convirtió en un tema centrada en el país
se espera que francia que tiene la
presidencia del consejo de la unión
europea siga intentando mediar en el
conflicto y denunciando las atrocidades
que se cometen en
los medios de presión son seguir estando
presentes ante la opinión pública
francesa recordar que la guerra continúa
recordar que las atrocidades continúan
los crímenes de guerra continúan las
autoridades rusas deben saber que el
apoyo no se debilita a pesar del
cansancio
los franceses han demostrado que están
especialmente abiertos a recibir
refugiados ucranianos y el estado tiene
el reto de responder por su atención
integral sin embargo la inmigración en
general y el manejo de la seguridad han
sido temas sensibles de esta compañía la
población francesa está muy dividida
sobre la cuestión de la inmigración y
una mayoría de franceses se dice
preocupada por el tema además el estado
tiene el desafío constante de gestionar
flujos migratorios a sus fronteras
distintos a los ucranianos
contra la inseguridad y el aumento de
los efectivos policiales fue un tema
clave para todos los candidatos si el
sentimiento de inseguridad sigue estable
con un 20 por ciento de franceses que
declara no sentirse en seguridad sobre
todo son las denuncias por las
violencias sexuales y de género que
explotaron en los últimos años